i don't know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] idiot what
this movie has the most [ __ ] words ever
no
no a mile they make an eight mile
reference here they do it they make one
in the movie
i feel like judd apatow came in and said
here's a joke for you every now and then
it was written down the hall and john
abbott kept walking by while the writers
were discussing [ __ ] and he was like oh
it's like this and they were like that's
really that's real good
you look like a mile yes
thank you judd thanks man for helping
out special thanks to judd apatow yeah
hey i'm ryan [ __ ] wright and i'm
[ __ ] jerry we're the movie critics
and us the movie critics we're gonna
give you
reasons to see it may be [ __ ] not to
see
we're the millers you [ __ ] idiot
reason is see number one jennifer
aniston is still hot
um this is reason to see number one when
i was watching this film
half a boner started appearing in my
pants really just just half
just half uh i was sitting next to you
so i felt a little uncomfortable if i
went a full boner
but it was awesome it was totally worth
it i just admire that you have such
impressive control over it was more like
natural
it was hard yeah it was hard anyway uh
she shows off her body a lot in this
movie she's not the greatest dancer
but [ __ ] what whoa damn you are like the
hottest
45 year old woman ever how old is she i
have no idea i was wondering that myself
god she looks great doesn't she
she does well and it is actually fitting
that that should be reason to see number
one this week because
part way through the movie i started to
realize that it seems like that's what
this movie sort of
wants you to come see because this movie
takes a break in the middle
to have a sequence which is basically
just going hey guys check it out
she's still super hot yeah she's
probably hotter than she was before
because she actually has to work at it
now reason to see number two
jason sedakis i like this guy a lot i
like him a lot too when i when i first
heard that he was the main character in
this film i was like can jason sedagas
really pull this off i had some
questions about mr sedakis
but you know what [ __ ] some movie
critics that i know
that don't like him he's [ __ ] awesome
i thought he was really funny there was
no question in my mind that he could
carry a movie like this i was just
afraid of
is he gonna get a good movie to carry
and he's one of those guys who always
makes me laugh and who at least
even when he's not doing something funny
is always really charming and believable
he's likeable he's a total [ __ ] but
you like him he's funny
reason to see number three jennifer
aniston's performance
jennifer aniston is so [ __ ]
hot we've already established that
performance is okay
we're moving on she's trying to be a
little bit more rated irish enter that
territory
you know she did like wanderlust and now
she's had horrible bosses and horrible
bosses i mean this is what she also had
jason sedegas how interesting all of
jennifer innocent movies now seem to be
like she's she's getting older but she's
still super hot
and also she's gonna be really raunchy a
lot now
and get away from that friendly image
because that seems to be the type of
role they want her to play now is
you know jennifer aniston if you really
pay attention her performances she's a
she's a very good actress
she's a great actress actually but she
gets put in these types of movies where
she doesn't get to show it off but
if you really pay attention even in this
film you're like you know she's got
comic timing down
beautifully besides the comedic part she
has to have moments of seriousness and
she does a great job at that too i kind
of hope that that both her
and jason's daycast can get a a better
script to to really shine with those
with those abilities because you know
they would have a cute baby they would
have a gorgeous baby
in fact if their whole family wasn't you
know adopted in this movie you know
maybe maybe they could maybe that's yeah
about where the miller is too
is that uh oh they get a biological
child in the word of the millers yeah
and then whoa ryan
destroying the set reason to see number
four
the virgin i wish i knew this guys
i wish i knew this guy's name too i
don't even remember his character's name
so that i mean it's not that hard to
google it before we record this
no we'll keep going guys all right it
gives a real
live feel if you don't know this but
actually when you
hit play we start recording this is live
all right yeah pause it
uh uh yeah uh the virgin in this film
he's a good funny actor who is this guy
i don't i don't know who he is
you know i'm actually i'm really glad to
to just that they cast him in this movie
because he
he has a strange look you know it's kind
of looking
he is kind of weird looking he just
looks like a guy though like it's kind
of neat because
you believe that this would just be some
guy who lived in jason siddiques
building and he's got really good
funny you know awkward comic timing
there's a line in there that really
stood out to me
where basically he's being asked you
know if he's gay or not and he says no
he's not gay and that he's straight and
i was watching this film as it
progressed i was like you know what
he was perfectly cast because i would
have believed him as either
gay or straight yeah what perfect that
is exactly true because when that scene
was going down
i was i was half wondering if they were
going to make him gay right there
reason is scene number five nick
offerman
i didn't know you were working on a nick
off or a minute yeah how was it it's
pretty good yeah i was like
because i wasn't even looking at you and
then you started talking i was like he's
doing nick
well done thank you thank you thank you
i was i was paying attention to his
voice from the movie i'm like i'm going
to attempt this
when i record tonight really so you
haven't been watching parks and rec or
something like that
oh no parks and recreation it's one of
my favorite shows
that was more of my nicholas cage i'm
gonna say
in revealing that you've watched more of
his work you're sounding less and less
like
yeah no he's really funny in this movie
though he's got another mustache he does
his strange but sincere guy thing and it
it works it's funny yeah it's he's he's
he can be
weird he can be normal he can be
so much and at the end of the day he's a
weird guy
but you love him for some reason this
sincere freaking guy
sincere freaky guy and he you know he's
got the timing you know i i can see
he's got that timing reason to see
number six
it actually gets you a few times yeah
you know this is not
i i i i'm finding myself i'm
pretty sure that i'm going to recommend
it but at the same time
i i was really watching it going this is
a pretty bad movie but
it also was making me go you know what
there's a lot of good in this movie at
the same time though it's a really
intermittent film because like whenever
you start to get bored and you're like
oh
then something really funny will happen
yeah like and that's legit
it won't even be like oh i guess i'll
laugh at this joke it'll be like
something very genuinely humorous comes
up and you're like
well done movie there's one joke where
two people laughed
really loud no wait one person laughed
really loud the other person not so much
and guess which guy
was the loud one there i don't even want
to spoil the line you might not
get it but there's one line they have
jason today and jennifer anderson are in
the rv together towards
the end of the movie and he's talking
about his name that's all i'm going to
say but i thought there was one joke and
it was really funny and it took a second
and then i
it hit me and yeah and i knew i was that
guy i was the one guy laughing super
loud
so you know we all have that day and i
knew i knew
i was the guy sitting next to that loud
guy reasons not to see number
one it's a beat sheet movie
let us explain um if you ever have read
a like screenwriting book save the cat
for example
for example for example or uh what is it
story or how to make a good script great
how to make a script in 21 days yeah you
know all these
all these screenwriting methods pretty
much have a
beat sheet which is like the main points
of your story
this movie felt like you were watching
flash cards yeah i was literally like
okay what's beat number one all right
we'll do that and then we'll shoot that
and then we'll shoot that and then we'll
shoot that and the dialogue felt so
it's joke joking yeah yeah yeah it's
like we gotta get these jokes out like
here we'll put a joke here we'll put a
joke here it's very systematical like
that yeah it's like
every two lines then joke every one they
know everything yeah
everything's felt so methodical reason
not to see number two
it's too convenient
literally every situation or predicament
they get in there is always something
convenient to help them get the [ __ ] out
of there
and yeah it's like deus ex mocking of
the movie it's it's like
something will happen they'll have five
minutes worth of jokes and uncomfortable
you know
tension for the characters and then
another random outside force will just
come in and make it be like oh that was
easy
yeah we're moving on you helped save the
millers again and you
didn't have to do that yeah reason not
to see number three
has a weird pace
how to describe the way this movie moved
this movie is sort of like an oreo to me
because it starts off and it's like okay
here's this guy
and drugs and then he's gonna get his
family together and then i gotta go on a
trip and they gotta get the drugs
and it's like part way you know five or
six minutes and i was sitting there
thinking what are you
in a hurry about like we're here for
this movie you don't need to get all
this [ __ ] out of the way so quickly it's
like
if you were to look at one of those beat
sheets like half of the beat sheet is
gone
by the time the first 20 minutes are out
after the midpoint of this movie
you know a midpoint think about it if
you don't know films where should a
midpoint occur
probably somewhere around the middle of
the film yeah it's like if you if you if
you think about the premise of this
movie
the midpoint occurs like 20 minutes into
this film yeah if you think about the
premise you know guys got to go and
assemble a fake family and go and get
these drugs and bring them back you
would probably assume that it would take
them half the movie to get to the drugs
and half the movie to get back from
getting the drugs
yeah this movie is like no no we're
gonna get the drugs in the first 20
minutes and then we're going to make
this a really long road trip movie for
the rest of it
reason not to see number four
you can really feel all four riders
we saw this movie together and when we
saw there were four writers on the
screen
we both knew we were in for an adventure
people because
four riders can always reassure you you
got a good movie
you know it's like i've seen a number of
superhero you know big tentpole
blockbusters and those
will have four or five writing credits
which doesn't always work but at least
sometimes you're like okay like this is
giant
yeah this is a you know the kind of
movie this is i don't
one person two people could have
effectively written this movie
we've got double that there are
different strands of humor running
through it i'm not going to say that
they don't
fit it all together but they do sort of
feel out of place because sometimes
things will be really absurd
and other times it'll be more wordy mean
you know humor
and then other times it'll be just off
the wall
so i it's like they broke comedy down
into many genres
yeah and then they then you could feel
that each writer
belonged to a certain genre maybe
subconsciously or something yes like
the absurdity guy you've got the banter
guy you've got the gross out
guy and then you've got the you know
other guy you've got and then you've got
the guy who's just like i just want to
get the plot out
yeah exactly you know so yeah it's you
do
feel the the wear and tear of having
four writers on that script
split decisions
roberts emma watson
no no emma roberts i like emma watson i
would
love to meet you emma watson i know
you're a fan of the show
what's up baby but emma roberts is in
this film you know playing that
character
first off i just don't like the writing
of the character another annoying
teenage
brat so i don't like it i don't like it
it's an annoying character type although
in this movie it didn't bug me so much
just because like
they gave us enough backstory on her to
get why she's that way because
i don't like her performance though at
all see i i did like her performance i
mean i enjoyed watching i don't think
you're hearing me i
i didn't like your performance i heard
you i
are you sure i did i i do i like her
performance and you don't
okay i'm all right i guess we're in a
disagreement it's a role that usually
becomes annoying
because and it is kind of annoying but
in this movie it wasn't like you know
we're an actual family but our daughter
just really hates us i kind of got like
she's a i mean they keep basically
establishing
that she doesn't have a home like she's
a street tough i thought the character i
don't really like the writing of the
character but i thought it was written
decently enough where another actress
could have pulled it off much better
oh i thought she did a good job i
thought she was fine yeah
i'm pretty sure we're in a disagreement
about this i'm pretty sure we
are our opinion is split you might even
say it's a
split decision shockingly
expected ryan's consensus
jennifer anderson's hot ass body
is the reason to see we are the millers
jennifer aniston's hot ass body is the
reason to see we are the millers
yeah she's hot and you know what the
film's pretty funny jerry's consensus
and all right comedy is the reason to
see
we're the millers and all right comedy
is the reason to see we're the millers
yeah you know it's it's really uneven
but the even
stuff is pretty funny it's pretty fun
the cast is all good
uh you know there are there are worse
comedies
it's better than identity it's better
way better than i did easy and the
hangover three hangover three sucked
all right guys thanks for checking out
our review for we are the millers
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below
and tell us what's your favorite
jennifer aniston thing
be a movie a body part whatever it is
and once you're done with that wash your
hands and then come over here and click
this here button
so you can see more episodes of reasons
to see and once you're done cleaning the
[ __ ] off your sheets
why don't you go ahead and follow us on
twitter and if you really like that
well then you're going to want to like
us on facebook and if you want to get
updated every time a new review or a
video is out
subscribe subscribe yep
come on because we are the movie critics
we are hey
there you go yep and you want to hear us
more
so you're gonna hit that button i feel
like we just segued into a
1950s product ad that's that's fine
because we are the movie critics
we are that's what we should have called
our show
we are the movie critics i feel like
that's way too like cocky
what are you talking about that would
have been awesome well let's go back in
time
i'm getting it there really yeah it's a
short outro it's different
yeah i don't think people really stick
around for this long answer
do you think they probably well it
depends who knows maybe it's
entertaining
maybe this is going to be the video and
it will still be entertaining
comment below and tell us if you've made
it to this point in the video
you